bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
deuxième vidéo de pourquoi sont ils si
unique la vidéo sur quand vous a
énormément plu et je tiens sincèrement à
vous remercier du fond du coeur pour
cette dernière aujourd'hui je souhaite
renouveler l'expérience
et vu que la fin de multi verse of
madness nautiz l'arrivée de clea et le
potentiel retour d'un certain
antagonistes eh bien j'aimerais
qu'aujourd'hui on se concentre sur
l'histoire de dormammu dormammu c'est le
plus grand ennemi de dr strange et c'est
un monstre de puissance souverain de la
dimension noir dans mammuth est un
antagoniste très atypique et unique en
son genre il possède une longue histoire
une incroyable origin story et j'ai
envie de mettre en lumière tout ça ne
tardons pas plus longtemps la vidéo est
conséquente donc accrochez-vous bien
nous allons voir ensemble pourquoi
dormammu est si unique
[Musique]
le bail
il
nous sommes le 11 août
1964 le comics strange tales numéro 126
vient de sortir une saga de comics qui
va nous partager deux histoires en une
d'un côté nous suivons des histoires
liées aux quatre fantastiques et
d'autres héros mais dans une seconde
lecture nous suivons les aventures d'un
dénommé dr strange que je pense vous
connaissez bien dans ses aventures
docteur strange est le disciple de
l'ancien le sorcier suprême des arts
mystique très respecté par ses
semblables et qu'on bat régulièrement un
dénommé baron bordeaux 1-1 ancien
disciple de l'ancien qui cherche à faire
tomber ce dernier ainsi que son élève
docteur strange sauf que dans le comics
strange days 126 après une énième
défaite du baron l'ancien va recevoir la
visite d'un message est fantomatique
ce message est à partie en fait à une
entité qui se fait appeler dormammu et
comme nous le présente l'ancien il y a
de quoi s'inquiéter car le terrible
dormammu est une menace très dangereuse
ses pouvoirs sont inégalées il est le
dirigeant ultime d'une dimension
constitué de ténèbres il n'a rien
d'humain ou de terriens et en plus de
cela son messager est en fait venu
annoncer que dormammu souhaite revenir
pour envahir la terre et malheureusement
le seul barrage empêchant la venue de
dormammu l ancien sauf qu'aujourd'hui
l'ancien est très âgé et très diminué
donc le seul à pouvoir arrêter cette
antagonistes c'est l'élève dr strange et
s'il échoue rien ne pourra stopper
dormammu donc la pression est grande
l'ancien va donc envoyer son disciple
dans cette étrange dimension où règne
cette nouvelle menace dormammu sera
témoin de l'arrivée de strange est
directement il va comprendre que si
l'ancien ne vient pas en personne c'est
qu'il est désormais trop faible pour se
mesurer à lui ce qui va le galvaniser
concernant son but de prendre la terre
en attendant dans cette dimension où le
temps et l'espace semble
ferrand de notre monde dr strange se
fraye un chemin pour arriver jusqu'à
dormammu il va affronter tour à tour de
nombreuses dires du dirigeant et cela va
attirer l'attention d'une jeune femme
provenant de la dimension noir cette
dernière est très surprise de voir que
ce n'est pas l'ancien qui a fait le
déplacement
mais une autre personne dont le courage
ne va pas la laisser insensible sauf que
malheureusement elle connaît dormammu
elle connaît son dirigeant elle sait que
le courageux protagonistes n'a aucune
chance face à son maître et dans un acte
de bonté elle va tenter de le convaincre
de faire demi tour mais elle ne connaît
pas strange ce dernier va évidemment
allé rencontrer dormammu face à l'entité
strange écoutent les revendications de
dormammu ce dernier lui dit d'aller
chercher l'ancien et qu'il est beaucoup
trop jeune pour pouvoir se mesurer à lui
strange va alors réfléchir et la jeune
femme va réapparaître devant lui pour
lui réaffirmer qu'il ne doit pas
affronter dormammu strain je lui
explique alors qu'il n'a pas le choix
même si dormammu est présenté comme
imbattable et surpuissant il doit
prévenir l'humanité d'une telle menace
sauf que ce n'était pas tout à fait ce
que la jeune femme voulait sous-entendre
dormammu en étant le dirigeant ultime de
la dimension sombre et bien en fait tout
est connecté à lui il est omnipotent là
bas c'est lui qui gère tout et par
extension c'est lui qui protège le
peuple et donc qui est la seule barrière
entre la dimension noir et le reste la
jeune femme va leur montrer à strange
que sa dimension est en fait à coller à
ce qu'elle appelle les mindless once
soit pour traduire vulgairement les
êtres sans esprit et ses êtres sont
primitifs sauvage et n'ont aucune
compassion il cherche simplement à tout
détruire et dormammu est en fait celui
qui protège le peuple de ses créatures
donc si strange même si personne ne le
croit véritablement
réussi à vaincre dormammu et bien
à dark dit mansion sera envahi par ces
créatures et tous ses habitants moore
strange est alors tiraillé car cela veut
dire que soient les habitants de la
terre meur soit ceux de la dark dit
mansion mais il n'aura pas le temps de
trop y réfléchir car dormammu sera au
fait que la jeune femme a échangé avec
le disciple et ce dernier eva la punir
pour cette erreur à combat va alors
éclaté entre strange et dormammu les
deux protagonistes vont envoyer
plusieurs sortilèges tour à tour sauf
que coup de théâtre à force de combattre
strange l'attention de dormammu est
focalisé sur ce dernier et par
conséquent la barrière qui retenaient
les mai-mai swans va s'effondrer
dormammu va alors instinctivement arrêté
le combat pour reformer la barrière sauf
qu'à cause du combat contre strange ses
pouvoirs se sont amoindries et il
n'arrive pas à repousser les êtres
primitifs strange va alors faire un coup
de maître ce dernier par le biais de ses
pouvoirs va aider dormammu à reformer la
barrière et ça va marcher strange vient
de sauver dormammu et sa dimension et là
un trait de caractère plutôt intéressant
va nous être montrée concernant dormammu
étant donné que strange la sauver ce
dernier ne peut le combattre
car son honneur l'empêchent de tuer son
sauveur et cela l'an rage strange va
alors profité de la situation pour lui
faire promettre que jamais il ne
s'attaquera à la terre et que jamais il
ne s'en prendra à la jeune femme qui a
aidé strange dormammu ne peut alors
faire autre chose que d'accepter et
strange repartira sur terre où il pourra
célébrer sa victoire
rien qu'avec ce premier comics nous
pouvons déjà souligné des éléments
intéressants alors que c'est la première
apparition de dorman dormammu est avant
tout là pour faire évoluer dr strange
lui proposer un nouveau challenge et le
mettre en difficulté
et même si mort d'eau et dormammu ne
semble rien avoir en commun pour le
moment et bien cela permet quand même de
nous proposer une sorte de quatuors
l'ancien et dr strange contre dormammu
le baron bordeaux nous le savons tous
mais docteur strange en tant que
disciples et destinés un jour à prendre
la place de l'ancien et devenir donc le
sorcier suprême donc lui faire affronter
dormammu c'est un moyen de lui faire
faire un pas vers ce nouveau rôle en
affrontant les mêmes ennemis que sont m
10 décembre 1964 c'est la sortie de
strange tales 130 et ce dernier va nous
conter une histoire répartis sur plus de
onze comics c'est le grand retour du
baron bordeaux sauf que quelque chose a
changé effectivement en bordeaux qui
n'arrête pas de se faire battre par
strange et l'ancien revient cette fois
ci accompagné de plusieurs speer il est
encore plus puissant que d'habitude il
est même devenu tellement puissant que
l'ancien et strange n'arriveront pas à
le battre et seront obligés de s'enfuir
et de se cacher il nous est finalement
révélé que bordeaux est en fait à lier à
dormammu qui cherchent à prendre sa
revanche sur strange sauf que à cause de
son serment de ne pas s'en prendre à la
terre dormammu ne peut plus agir de lui
même c'est pourquoi il est venu à la
rencontre de bordeaux il a boosté ce
dernier avec ses pouvoirs et en échange
ce dernier doit détruire strange et
l'ancien les seule barrière l'empêchant
de prendre le contrôle de la terre
désormais seuls strange valeur chercher
un moyen de les arrêter et après
plusieurs cavale et affrontements va
trouver une piste eternity c'est
l'ancien lui même qui dans le coma va
donner la solution a strange la clé pour
trouver eternity est en fait son
amulette soit le plus communément appelé
un oeil dagg à moto strange va s'en
servir et une porte vers une autre
dimension va s'ouvrir là-bas le docteur
strange va faire la rencontre
d'eternity lui même un être ultra
cosmique la personnification du temps
aussi vieux que l'univers l'entité va
apporter sa sagesse a strange et lui
révélé que ce dernier n'a pas besoin
d'avoir plus de pouvoir pour vaincre
mort d'eau et dormammu la clé de la
victoire ce n'est pas la force mais la
sagesse strange doit être plus malin que
ses adversaires et agir avec réflexion
de retour dans notre réalité strange
part affronter bordeaux boosté par les
pouvoirs de dormammu nous apprenons
d'ailleurs que la jeune femme qui est
venu parler à strange dans les premiers
comics a trahi dormammu dans le but que
strange gagne du temps le souverain de
la dimension sombre l'a donc enfermés
comme punition ce qui va donner une
motivation en plus a strange de sortir
victorieux de ce combat grâce aux
conseils d'eternity strange bah non sans
mal mort d'eau dormammu enragé que son
laquais est encore échouer et va
téléporter tout le monde dans une
dimension neutre afin de combattre
strange en duel ou la magie ne seraient
pas utilisés le roi de la dimension noir
va convoquer tous les autres dirigeants
des dimensions qu'il a assujetti afin
que ces derniers soient témoins de sa
victoire ultime sur strange
malheureusement strange prend le dessus
sur dormammu est mort d'eau qui était en
train de regarder le combat va
intervenir et jeter un sort sur strange
pour donner la victoire à son maître
sauf que ce n'est pas comme ça que
fonctionne dormammu même si il ay
strange et souhaite de tout coeur sa
mort il y à des enjeux politiques
derrière les souverains des autres
dimensions regarde le combat dormammu
est immensément puissant aussi donc il y
adeux l'honneur derrière et beaucoup
d'ego sa réaction sera alors à la
hauteur de sa colère bordeaux sera
bannie dans une autre dimension seul le
combat peut alors reprendre néanmoins
l'issue de l'affrontement ne changera
pas strange ressort vainqueur et en plus
de cela ils les vainqueurs alors qu'il
ya eu tentative de triche de la part de
mort d'eau donc la défaite est encore
plus lourdes pour dormammu le prix de la
défaite sera qu dormammu en plus de ne
pas pouvoir s'attaquer à la terre promet
qu'il n'utilisera plus et pouvoir contre
cette dernière donc booster quelqu'un
d'autre avec sa puissance pour attaquer
la terre c'est terminé bien que la
présence d'eternity peut sembler anodine
dans cette histoire elle en fait une
grande importance car elle permet de
nous montrer nous expliquer pourquoi
strange sort victorieux de ces combats
face à dormammu qui nous a été présentée
comme une entité ultime imbattable et
beaucoup trop puissant la clé ce n'est
pas la force et c'est ce qui fait défaut
à dormammu strange a conscience que son
ennemi est beaucoup plus puissant que
lui mais ce n'est pas une fatalité de
par sa sagesse et son esprit tacticien
strange a par deux fois trouvé la
solution pour détourner la victoire
dormammu aveuglé par ses immenses
pouvoirs et son trône dans la dimension
noir se perd dans son agressivité et du
coup se fait avoir bêtement par son
ennemi et vous allez le voir cette
agressivité va le pousser à faire de
très grosses erreurs au point même de
tout perdre bien qu'il soit réapparu
dans strange days 144 en envoyant
quelqu'un tu es strange en son nom ce
qui va échouer bien sûr le comics qui
nous intéresse est plutôt le 146
dormammu enrage d'avoir été humiliés et
vaincu par strange trois fois de suite
l'imbattable et le surpuissant dormammu
a été battue et par quelqu'un de moins
puissant que lui et ce devant les
dirigeants des dimensions soumise est au
courant que strange a rencontré eternity
dormammu dans sa colère va convoquer le
sorcier dans la dimension de l'entité
cosmique dans le but de les détruire
tous les deux une action qui est
complètement démesuré et qui traduit la
folie de dormammu à cause de son
agressivité et sa colère comme je vous
l'expliquais eternity est une
incarnation de l'univers marvel
il est la personnification du temps lui
même il est un dieu pour les dieux donc
voilà l'issue vous vous en doutez
dormammu et eternity vont se combattre
sous les yeux de strange dormammu va
disparaître sans qu'on sache s'il est
réellement mort et aussi étonnant que
cela puisse paraître eternity va lui
aussi disparaître même si on se doute
fortement qu'une incarnation de ce type
ne puisse mourir comme ça dormammu nous
rappelle au final quand même par ce
combat à quel point il est puissant
néanmoins rappelez vous du premier
comics dont on a parlé dans la vidéo je
vous disais que dormammu étaient liés à
la dimension noir que c'est lui qui
gérait tout là bas est bien le fait que
ce dernier était vaincu et a disparu ne
sera pas sans conséquence la disparition
de dormammu va libérer tous les êtres
qui l'a banni ou enfermés dans d'autres
dimensions c'est donc le retour de
bordeaux le retour de la jeune femme qui
est venue en aide à strange car dormammu
l'avait bannie pour ses trahisons cette
dernière va d'ailleurs nous révéler son
véritable nom cléa et il semblerait que
strange ne soit pas insensible à cette
dernière la vie va donc reprendre
tranquillement son cours mais pas pour
très longtemps car un nouveau personnage
entre en scène parmi les personnes
libérées de leur bannissement dans
d'autres dimensions parra dormammu se
trouvait une femme du nom de oumar et
oumar ce n'est pas n'importe qui
puisqu'il s'agit de la soeur de dormammu
lui même cette dernière va prendre le
contrôle de la dimension noir et
s'ériger en tant que souveraine et dans
le but de se venger de son frère oumar
va se confronter à strange et pour cela
elle va retenir cléa en otage strange va
réussir à la libérer mais le problème
c'est kumar est autant voire plus
dangereuses et maléfique que son frère
donc les à court un grave danger pour la
protéger l'ancien va l'envoyer dans une
autre dimension dans le but kumar ne la
retrouve jamais mais par extension
strange non plus et il le vit mal car ce
dernier commence à tomber amoureux de la
jeune femme après quelques temps et
plusieurs péripéties dr strange décide
d'aller retrouver clia l'amour prend le
dessus sur la sagesse et cela va avoir
des conséquences
strange je vais utiliser leurs blagues à
moto pour la retrouver il va aller la
chercher sauf que pas de chance la
dimension ou cléa a été envoyée se
trouve être en fait aussi la dimension
ou dormammu a atterri après son combat
contre eternity dormammu va alors nous
révéler ce qu'il s'est passé il aurait
dû mourir face à eternity il s'y
attendait mais il a survécu et s'est
retrouvé dans ce qu'il appelle la
dimension inconnue là bas il a fait face
à des démons nommé les dix corses qui
ont tenté de le tuer mais bon on parle
quand même de dormammu le souverain
ultime de la dimension noir en deux
temps trois mouvements il a vaincu les
dix corse et leurs dirigeants ce qui les
a forcés à prêter allégeance à dormammu
qu'ils connaissent bien au final car son
empire s'étend sur plusieurs dimensions
qu'il a assujetti bref dans ma mousse et
reconstruit et malheureusement l'arrivée
de strange dans la dimension pour sauver
clés à 1 en fait lever la barrière de la
dimension inconnue maintenant libérés et
dormammu va invoquer oumar sa soeur et
nouvelle dirigeante de la dimension noir
pour lui rappeler qui est le véritable
souverain de leur royaume pendant ce
temps-là strange va sauver cléa avant de
partir affronter dormammu sauf qu'il va
perdre dormammu bas alors tenter de
sortir de la dimension mes clés à grâce
à sa magie va manipuler ou marais se
servir d'elle pour sauver strange le
sort s'est libéré va conduire dormammu à
un affrontement sur la terre se
rappelant des serments de dormammu à
l'égard de la planète les pouvoirs de
l'entité sont donc amoindri là-bas et
strange prend du coup facilement le
dessus sur ce dernier qui sera poussé à
fuir et va retourner dans la dark du
match n 5 ans plus tard dans avengers ce
numéro 115 sorti en 1973 nous retrouvons
dormammu dans le prologue du comics ce
dernier va sauver loki qui vient de
subir une
hyland défaite face à son frère d'or
qu'il a même rendu aveugle dormammu qui
a toujours était imbu de lui même et
aveuglé par sa puissance se remet en
quelque sorte en question l'antagoniste
prend conscience de l'absurdité et du
problème que génèrent ces promesses
faites à strange suite à ces défaites
car par conséquent il ne peut confronter
strange frontalement il est complètement
impuissant sur terre face aux sorciers
dormammu va alors concevoir un plan il
souhaite utiliser un artefact du nom des
villas y soit le mauvais oeil c'est un
artefact qui lui permettrait d'étendre
sa dimension et de la fusionner avec
d'autres et ce malgré ses promesses car
c'est l'objet qui ferait tout dormammu
n'aurait pas besoin d'utiliser
véritablement ses pouvoirs sur terre
problème personne ne sait où se trouvent
les villes aïe
à part un certain groupe de terriens les
defender sauf que autre problème les
defender sont sur terre donc voilà c'est
compliqué pour dormammu d'agir c'est
pourquoi il a sauvé loki l'eau qui va
servir d'agent terrestre pour dormammu
et en échange ce dernier lui a affirmé
qu'il lui rendrait la vue en secret
dormammu pour mettre à bien son plan a
pris connaissance des agissements des
héros de la terre il s'avère que black
knight aurait été changé en pierre et
son âme est perdue quelque part strange
via l'orb d'agde à moto va rappeler
l'âme de black knight sauf que dormammu
va l'intercepter et lui lancer un
sortilège qui fait que l'homme de black
knight ne peut retourner dans son corps
ce qui va faire germer l'idée a strange
que le seul moyen de sauver black knight
et d'utiliser les villes aïe les
défendeurs sont alors se mettre en quête
de l'artefact et élément qui pèse son
poids c'est que black knight est un
héros reconnu sur terre et fait partie
notamment des avengers loki le dieu de
la malice et de la discorde va donc
intervenir pour faire émerger l'idée que
black knight aurait été vaincus par les
diffuseurs ce qui serait la nouvelle
menace
terre des tensions vont alors se crée
entre les avengers et les diffuseurs se
créant une sorte de mini civil war entre
les deux groupes une aubaine pour les
antagonistes
à terme les défendeurs souvent on
retrouver les morceaux de lévis la haye
et vont leur forme et dormammu va alors
se révéler et volets l'objet l'érigeant
automatiquement en tant que plus grande
menace de l'univers car il peut
désormais faire tout ce qu'il veut dites
vous que même le watchers ou à tout
viendra voir la scène grâce à son
nouveau jouet dormammu va battre non
sans mal à la fois les avengers et les
defender mais ne respectant jamais ses
subordonnés loki qui s'est fait trahir
par dormammu va se rebeller contre ce
dernier offrant une fenêtre d'action à
la scarlet witch qui va attaquer
dormammu et ce dernier va se faire
aspirer par les villas y provoquant sa
disparition encore une fois alors que
dormammu a toutes les cartes en main
pour réussir son ego et son aveuglement
l'empêchent d'atteindre la victoire mais
l'histoire ne s'arrête pas là pour tout
vous dire le watchers étaient présents
car ils savaient que dormammu allait
perdre néanmoins il a quand même prévenu
strange par la suite ce n'est pas la fin
de l'entité quelques temps plus tard
alors que strange et cléa vivent le
parfait amour oumar réapparaissent sur
terre pour affronter strange inquiète
par son retour le docteur désirent se
rendre dans la dimension noir mais
étrangement cléa ne souhaite pas la
compagnie stephen par alors seul là-bas
cléa qui est resté sur terre va alors
être témoin d'un esprit agonisant en
train de l'appeler ce même esprit va
téléporter cléa au centre de la terre où
cette dernière va faire la lourde de
découverte que dormammu est encore là et
est en train de se reconstruire
maintenant au courant que dormammu est
de retour l'esprit va occuper le
souverain déchu pour que cléa puis
s'enfuir et prévenir strange l'oea va
voyager jusqu'à la dimension noir ou
strange est en train de confronter le
plus proche disciple de dormammu est là
grosse révélation ce fameux disciples
s'appelle en fait origny et est le père
de clea c'est pourquoi la jeune femme ne
voulait pas se rendre dans la dimension
clé à va nous apprendre qu'à une
certaine époque son père était
clairement le lien entre le peuple de la
dimension sombre et les dirigeants
soient dormammu et oumar pendant ce
temps là où marc a rejoint dormammu au
centre de la terre c'est en fait grâce à
elle que ce dernier a survécu une partie
de l'essence de dormammu est resté sur
terre et oumar l'a aidé à se reformer
maintenant reconstruit dormammu se
déchaîne et commence à faire un carnage
sur terre de l'autre côté les deux
amants vont s'échapper de la dimension
noir poursuivi par aurigny c'est alors
que coup de théâtre oumar révèle son
véritable plan elle s'est en fait servi
de l'art formation de dormammu dont le
but de lui voler tous ses pouvoirs une
fois qu'il serait revenu maintenant
aussi puissante qu'une déesse oumar
devient un véritable monstre de
puissance au point même qu'elle va
menacer aurigny apeurés par sa
dirigeante au riz ni va parler du bon
vieux temps à homards et va nous en
dévoiler encore plus sur la famille de
clés à quand il était jeune or signé
omar sont tombés amoureux et de cette
union naquit une jeune humaine qui est
en fait cléa oumar et la mère de clea
mais allez savoir pourquoi la naissance
de sa fille a été un choc pour oumar qui
a pété les plombs au point de la renier
et d'oublier qu'elle a donné naissance à
un enfant aurait ni a alors élevées cléa
dans le plus grand des secrets bref
strange cléa et oumar s'affrontent sauf
que pendant le combat dormammu revient
et reprend ses pouvoirs à omar
finalement l'esprit qui a averti cléa du
retour du souverain déchu intervient il
s'agit en fait de gaia l'esprit de la
terre et de la nature et qui est très en
colère à cause de dormammu qui s'est
servi des ressources et de l'énergie de
la terre pour surfer j'ai accompagné de
l'esprit déchaîné strange et cléa
viennent finalement à bout de dormammu
et origny ramène le corps inconscients
d'oumar dans la dark diman che dormammu
réapparaît par la suite dans les comics
30 et 31 de ghost rider où il tentera de
manipuler ce dernier pour le confronter
à son ennemi juré nous le retrouverons
également dans les comics de thor avec
la fameuse partie d'échecs entre lui et
odin qui se terminera sur un match nul
enfin dormammu sera de retour dans les
comics dr strange volume de houle
antagonistes va voyager dans le temps
pour se rebâtir dans le passé et il va
se servir de mort d'eau ainsi que du
grand père de ce dernier pour effectuer
sa reconstruction quelque temps plus
tard clé avons organisé une rébellion
contre oumar redevenue la dirigeante de
la dimension noir puisque bas dormammu
est absent strange va se joindre au
combat et cléa va réussir à faire tomber
omar et devenir la nouvelle dirigeante
de l'adar guy mansion où elle apportera
la paix et la lumière au passage elle
apprendra d'ailleurs à oumar qu'elle est
en fait sa fille en 1988 sort les
premiers comics de doctor strange
sorcerer supprime et c'est pour moi une
saga de comics très intéressant car je
trouve que ce sont vraiment eux qui vont
mettre en lumière l'histoire de dormammu
et nous proposer une apogée pour le
personnage bon on peut mentionner un
énième retour de l'antagoniste dans le
comics numéros 1 et 2 de cette série
personnellement je pense que c'était
pour nous proposer une certaine vibe
nostalgique dormammu et plus grand
ennemi de strange et qui dit nouvelle
série de comics dit nouvelle histoire et
une nouveau dessin donc voilà mais ce
qui va nous intéresser ce sont les
comics 21 à 24 de la série bien
évidemment l'histoire va nous conter
encore une fois le grand retour de
dormammu mais cette fois ci les comics
vont nous proposer en parallèle une
origin story complète du personnage et
de son règne dans la dimension noir en
fait tout du long de l'épopée de
dormammu depuis 1964 nous avons par ci
par là des petits éléments de l'or qui
reste inexpliquée par exemple nous avons
une brève explication de l'origine de
dormammu dents doctor strange volume de
numéro 71 mais elle est quand même pas
mal à complète des fois des mots sont
prononcés comme fight in hussain y faire
mais nous n'avons jamais de véritables
backstory personnellement je pense que
cela traduisait les doutes des
dessinateurs quant au personnage de
dormammu même si il savait à peu près la
direction qu'il voulait prendre pour
l'antagoniste et bien rien n'avait
jamais été vraiment établie sauf qu'au
bout d'un moment il faut expliquer le
pourquoi du comment dormammu a bien
évolué en 30 ans et une panoplie de
personnages liés à ce dernier sont
apparus par exemple question toute bête
mais oumar qui est la soeur de dormammu
et bien pourquoi cette dernière est l
humaine alors que dans mamou n'a pas du
tout cette forme et bien nous allons
découvrir tout ça ensemble
le comics commence par nous expliquer
quelques concepts en rapport avec le
multivers les univers et les dimensions
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que la dark
demon est une dimension majeure à coller
et en boîte et à ce qu'on appelle des
dimensions de poche et du coup la dark
the mansion étant la dimension majeure
possède un impact sur les dimensions
adjacentes voilà par exemple la
dimension des mindless once les
créatures primitives introduite dans les
comics strange days c'est une dimension
de poche accolé à la dark the mansion
dormammu avait même établi une barrière
si vous vous rappelez et du coup parce
que la vie a pu se former dans la
dimension noir les dimensions de poche
ont pu l'accueillir aussi et sous
plusieurs formes propres à chaque
dimension c'est pourquoi les mindless
once sonné quand la vie s'est formée une
race de sorcier appelé mourouk a réussi
à comprendre et maîtriser l'énergie qui
composaient la dimension noir grâce à
ses nouveaux pouvoirs les mourouk ont pu
dominer civilisé et garder la dark team
and sun ce qui va conduire à une ère
prospère et de paix qui va durer pendant
vingt-huit mille ans sauf qu'à la fin de
ses 28 années un nouveau règne débute
avec un nouveau roi mourouk aulnes art
et halenar c'est quelqu'un qui regrette
un peu les gloires passées et les
conquêtes c'est alors que deux êtres
apparaissent dans la dimension deux
êtres du nom de dormammu et oumar le
frère et la soeur nous dévoile qui sont
en fait des fugitifs de leur dimension
d'origine la dimension fault in pour
faire simple la dimension fall tine est
une dimension très ancien est encore
plus majeur que la dimension noir là bas
nous y retrouvons d être composé de pure
énergies cosmiques ceux qui font d'eux
des êtres immensément puissant parmi les
plus redoutables entités qui composent
l'existence le but des fal tignes 1 et
de générer et emmagasiner le plus
d'énergie possible afin d'accroître la
communauté et la grande île du coup pour
ce faire les fal tignes un par le biais
d'une combinaison d'énergie peuvent
donner naissance à un autre fall tignes
un qui seront dévoués à leurs géniteurs
et permettront la croissance du peuple
sait ce qui va se passer pour le fal
tignes un cypher mais allez savoir
pourquoi ce dernier va donner naissance
non pas à un fall tignes un mais deux
dormammu et oumar et les nouveau nés
seront différents des autres fall tignes
un car ils ne seront pas du tout dévoués
à leurs géniteurs et même pire que ça
ils seront attirés par la plus perverse
dépenser pour leurs peuples il convoite
la matière cypher tentera de les arrêter
mais les jeunes fall tignes 1 vont le
tuer en le changeant en boule de
matières ce qui va les conduire à leur
bannissement après leur expulsion les
deux frères et soeurs vont se rendre en
compte en parcourant les dimensions que
la plupart étaient composés de matières
qui n'attendait que de se faire dévorer
et assimilés bref le rêve pour dormammu
et oumar en gros ces derniers vont
finalement arrivée à la darse diman che
comme on l'a mentionné juste auparavant
et voyant tout le potentiel de cette
dimension ils seront très intéressé par
cette dernière dormammu et omar vont
vanter leur pouvoir auprès du roi hall
narre dans le but de prouver leur
utilité le frère et la soeur vont faire
miroiter à aulnat que grâce à eux ils
peuvent étendre la dark team and sean et
absorber les autres dimensions pour
agrandir le royaume en réalité ils ont
le pouvoir de le faire mais c'était un
piège tendu à aulnat rpt et son peuple
quand la conquête a commencé dormammu et
homards ont guidé honnart vers la
dimension des mindless once et ces
derniers ont fait un carnage il y a eu
énormément de morts et parmi les décès
nous retrouvons le roi hall nar le frère
et la soeur ont alors bâti une barrière
entre la dimension noir et celle des
miles once permettant la survie du
peuple bien évidemment par le biais de
cette action le peuple a déclaré
dormammu et oumar comme les grands
sauveurs de la dark dit mansion étant
donné que le fils dole nar or il n'y
était beaucoup trop jeune pour régner
dormammu et oumar ont été nommés régions
du royaume malheureusement pour oumar la
bataille l'a grandement affaibli ce qui
l'a poussé naturellement à être au
second plan laissant la place
majoritaire à son frère par la suite
dormammu accompagné d'oumar ont fait
bannir les derniers grands sorciers
mourouk pour éviter que ces derniers
deviennent une menace un jour grâce à la
matière oumar et dormammu ont pris une
forme humaine mettant désormais au
pouvoir dormammu décida de délaisser
cette forme pour reprendre en partie
celle des fighting pendant que le
nouveau souverain a régné sur le royaume
au riz ni le fils d'anna est normalement
le roi légitime a depuis bien grandi et
est devenu un adulte oumar et lui se
sont rapprochés et vous savez ce qui va
se passer cléa va naître mais comme je
vous disais on ne sait pas pourquoi
oumar va péter un câble eh bien nous
avons désormais la raison lors de la
naissance de clé à omar s'est rendu
compte qu'elle a donné vie à une humaine
et cela va lui créer un traumatisme à
cause de cette naissance oumar se rend
compte qu'elle est en fait incapable de
revenir à sa forme natale de fall team
yen et à cause de cela sa santé mentale
va se dégrader au point de devenir
violente et même de trahir dormammu
c'est comme ça qu'elle se fera bannir
avant de revenir quand dormammu va
perdre face à eternity avoir enfin une
origine story concernant dormammu est
également oumar permet de solidifier les
personnages cela nous permet de mieux
les comprendre et par extension de plus
s'attacher à dormammu de par sa
condition de fall tignes 1 est un être
unique et surpuissant donc ce n'est pas
étonnant de le voir se hisser et ce peu
importe la dimension parmi les leaders
surtout que c'est un être en plus très
déterminé il vient d'une dimension
majeure inégalée par la plupart donc le
pouvoir est inné chez lui mais
malheureusement c'est aussi ce qui lui
fait défaut à force d'être supérieur à
la plupart des êtres vivants de
l'existence dormammu sous-estiment trop
souvent ses adversaires car il a trop
confiance en ses pouvoirs il fonce
toujours tête baissée car de toute façon
à chaque fois à 99% du temps la
puissance l'emportent car il déborde
d'énergie mais face à un tacticien comme
strange quelqu'un de sage et qui utilise
sa tête et bien dormammu se fait avoir
et les conséquences sont ultra lourdes
par la suite alors qu'il aurait pu
éviter ça strange en tant que héros
évolue grâce à dormammu mais au final ce
dernier lui aussi évolué grâce à strange
strange fait se remettre en question
dormammu sans qu'ils ne s'en rendent
véritablement compte là où ce dernier ne
misait toujours que sur la force brute
ses défaites l'ont obligé à chaque
retour à mettre en place des plans pour
se venger de strange dans ces mêmes
comics de doctor strange sorcerer
supprime dormammu va réussir à reprendre
la dark dit mansion aklea et art
fusionner avec pour devenir surpuissant
nostalgique du bon vieux temps dormammu
souhaite ramener omar et que cette
dernière gouverne avec lui mais
malheureusement cette dernière va le
trahir une nouvelle fois l'obligeant à
punir et bagnères sa soeur oumar ayant
finalement accepté avec le temps
l'existence de sa fille s'alliera avec
elle et strange pour combattre son frère
est mort d'eau contre toute attente se
joindra également à la fête néanmoins
cette alliance a un prix oumar veut
faire un deal avec clé à elle reprend la
gouvernance de la dimension noir en
compagnie de bordeaux dont elle semble
tomber amoureuse en échange de son aide
finalement le deal sera acceptée et tous
les quatre réussirons à battre dormammu
l'oeuf à tignes un déchire reviendra
quelques comics plus tard encore une
fois et réussira à duper cléa et omar
absorbant sa soeur au passage redevenu
un être immensément puissant strange va
réunir les différentes earth pour
l'affronter mais cette fois ci le combat
sera plutôt intriguant car strange
obtiendra la victoire en faisant
remettre en question les choix de
dormammu puisque ce dernier est si
puissant et si unique pourquoi pertile
son temps avec la terre alors qu'il ya
mieux ailleurs pourquoi for style depuis
toutes ces années face à strange alors
qu'il les choux à chaque fois prenons
conscience de l'absurdité de la
situation
dormammu va s'en aller afin de partir en
quête d'un but plus intéressant que de
convoiter la terre
légaux de dormammu a tant fait parler
c'est à se demander s'il a toujours
véritablement convoité la terre au fond
de lui grâce à sa puissance ine dans
mammuth a toujours réussi à avoir ce
qu'il convoitait facilement et doctor
strange est la première véritable
résistance dont dormammu n'arrive pas à
venir à bout tout comme l'ancien
d'ailleurs qu'il l'avait déjà battue à
l'époque s'ils dorment hameau convoite
la terre c'est parce que strange s'y
trouvent et qu'il n'arrive pas à
accepter qu'ils puissent se faire battre
par ce dernier durant toutes ces années
dormammu s'est enfermé dans une spirale
et une escalade de haine et
d'agressivité qui au final lui fera tout
perdre à cause de son ego et son
aveuglement pour strange dormammu est
capable de tout et des pires atrocités à
cause de ça il ne réussira jamais à
redorer sa liaison avec sa soeur aussi
maigre a été cette relation pareil pour
que les a au contraire cela poussera
même la jeune femme elle trahir c'est
également le cas pour la politique dans
ma mot a perdu le contrôle de la
dimension noir à plusieurs reprises et
par conséquent c'est aussi une perte
d'énergie et de pouvoir puisque
normalement il s'alimente par le biais
de la dimension noir dormammu est un
être exceptionnel de puissance est
capable de tout mais il a préféré perdre
son temps avec strange à cause de son
ego alors qu'il pourrait voir ailleurs
et convoité et d'autres objectifs et
d'autres dimensions et c'est un point
qui est vraiment dommage car du coup on
a du mal à cerner dormammu dans
l'univers marvel à cause de ça en tant
que fan tignes un exilé et dormammu
pourrait devenir quelque chose
d'incontrôlable obligeant même le
tribunal vivent d'intervenir après tout
odin le considère comme son égal à
camotos n'arrivait pas toujours à le
battre dormammu est même capable de
confronter les célestes méphisto a déjà
fait alliance avec lui et en termes de
hiérarchie mephisto n'était qu'un sol
d'un pur dans mame ou même les gardiens
avec doom dans un autre univers ont
utilisé le pouvoir de dorment à meaux
pour abattre ego la planète vivante donc
voilà bref vous avez compris ce que je
veux dire dormammu l'équivalent d'un
dieu mais c'est un être qui possède trop
de puissance comparé à son mental mais
en même temps est-ce qu'on peut
réellement lui en vouloir neffati mien
mais différente ses congénères son exil
l'a obligé à grandir et à se former tout
seul avec oumar est alors qu'il était
encore jeune le fait qu'un être
débordant d'énergie convoitant la
matière atterri dans des dimensions ou
la matière est abondante et bien c'est
comme un enfant dans un magasin de
bonbons dormammu ne peut résister il ne
peut être raisonnable et cela le conduit
à une folie des grandeurs en soi d'un
amour et le plus grand ennemi de doctor
strange et le restera et je suis très
curieux de voir son potentiel retour
dans le mc eu et tout ce que je vous
raconte depuis le début de la vidéo et
bien c'est tout ça qui rend dormammu si
unique
la vidéo s'arrête là et bon sens elle
était bien longue j'espère que cela ne
vous aura pas ennuyé mais le truc c'est
que si on veut parler de dormammu eh
bien on est un peu obligé en même temps
de développer l'histoire de quatre
personnages dormammu du coup mais on est
obligé aussi de parler de oumar de clea
et du coup pas de docteur strange dans
tous les cas j'espère voir de
l'innovation concernant dormammu dans le
mc eu notamment pourquoi pas
l'apparition de oumar et tout le concept
de dimensions majeures et mineures
j'espère que la vidéo vous aura plu j'ai
pris un plaisir monstre à la faire et je
crois même que la vidéo est plus longue
que celle de gang mais bon je peux pas
le dire actuellement quoi j'attends bien
évidemment vos retours comme vous le
savez c'est un concept qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur donc voilà je
compte sur vous pour me dire si la vidéo
était bien s'il ya des choses à
améliorer et cetera etc n'hésitez pas
non plus à me dire quel personnage vous
aimeriez voir dans un prochain pourquoi
sont ils si unique un très grand merci à
vous d'être arrivé jusque là n'oubliez
pas le petit pouce bleus et à vous
abonner à la chaîne on se retrouve très
prochainement cet argot rock allez ciao
tout le monde
[Musique]